ben
is in nashville hi ben welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey uh mr ramsay thank you for taking my
call sure
um i've been through financial peace
university
and i learned a lot through that and
i started paying off some debt um
basically i've made some bad decisions
here in the last
five months and i don't want to try to
validate it with
excuses so i'll just tell you where i'm
at um
i make about 95 000 a year uh it's in an
unstable
market in construction management so i'm
not really guaranteed that job
two months from now but that's what i've
made
in the last year and i've got uh
nineteen thousand dollars in student
loans
and an eighty three thousand dollar
mortgage and that's all my debt
and then this summer i decided to go buy
a sixty nine thousand dollar vehicle and
i'm a single man 36 years old and um
in that time i met the woman of my
dreams in the last three months
that has she listened to dave ramsey as
well so it blew my mind and i'm just
like
what have i done i had a mentor that i
told
what i was doing and buying a vehicle
and obviously i said i know this is not
a smart
decision it's almost as much as my
mortgage so i said but i can afford the
payments right now i'm good
so that's my situation i know i've made
some mistakes
and i'm i'm i'm coming to you now
because
since i've met her i kind of
kind of want to get out from uh from the
debt even faster
and i don't know if you would recommend
maybe just selling this vehicle
getting out from under it paying off
what uh what i'm going to lose on
selling it
and move on
[Music]
so what'd your mentor say when you told
him you're gonna buy a 69 000 truck
well i i didn't tell him until after it
was done he just saw it in the parking
lot
and uh i could see his eyes kind of
raised you know like oh okay well
you know it was almost that second-hand
embarrassment that i could feel through
him
um that's fair so yeah what happened
that that hit that domino that made you
go by that did something happen in your
life you get tired you get burnt out you
exhausted
what happened well if i look back yeah i
was in a long relationship
about nine years and i just got out of
that in march and um
i bought this vehicle about three months
ago thinking hey i'm out you know i have
very little debt
um my nieces and nephew were two and a
half hours three hours away
and uh now they've moved within 30
minutes
and they're being homeschooled and i'd
like to be near them
so i was like you know let's get a
vehicle that can get the whole family
uh involved including those three kids
and
you know mom and dad too and uh
for 69 000 they all ought to be able to
live in it
yeah i do uh okay all right well here's
the thing
how old are you 36.
you said that earlier i'm sorry um i
have done so many stupid things in my
life
that have cost me so much money and
embarrassment
and shame and when i do something stupid
i call it stupid tax that i have to pay
and part of stupid taxes money and part
of it is just i look in the mirror and i
go you're a
doofus and i kind of hear that's what
you're doing right now am i missing
something
no it sums it up yeah after meeting her
i realized that
no you knew it all along she just made
you admit it you knew it when you drove
it off the lot you were just holding
your nose hoping the smell wasn't gonna
go away
you knew it there you knew it because
you had been trained by
us you've been through financial peace
university you knew it you knew when you
called me what i was going to say you
hid it from your mentor that's the big
you made it into a secret that's how you
really knew yeah you knew
you knew all along so here's the thing
anytime i do and i'm not picking on you
because i've done dumber things i've
done 690 000
stupid things you're only 69 000. you'll
survive this but
uh the trick is not what to do with this
the trick is to do enough of an autopsy
on your psyche
and on yourself to where you freaking
never do this again
that's a big deal why because it's a
pattern
and if you don't change the pattern
you're screwed
because if i engage in a pattern of
stupidity
that then makes me called stupid and
you you know you gotta you gotta no
longer do that so
to be worthy of this girl is what you're
the noble the calling inside of your
heart you wanna be a
wise young gentleman not a
not the doofus that you saw in the
mirror after you bought the truck and
so but if she dumps you in three months
yeah it's still the right thing to not
have bought
but the motivation is very noble right
and that can cause you to go i'm going
to break this pattern when i went broke
the motivation was noble i said
i am never going to be here again i'm
never going to be in a situation where i
can't feed my kids again i'm embarrassed
my stupidity has caused my family to
have the lights cut off the water cut
off
my wife is ready to leave i because of
my stupidity i have to stop
the stupid and i had to do a csi on why
i did the things i did that set me up
for the fall
and i had to never do them again so
that's what's important the truck
is just the symptom does that make sense
ben
it does so if you dig this out and this
is like the dumbest
last thing you ever do in this category
that's a huge win if you just sell the
truck and you don't dig it out
and you go back next time there's
something going on and you go buy a boat
and you go wow i just want to get a boat
and i just thought well i can afford the
payments you know same thing you did
last time
then you're going to just replicate this
and you're going to be what's known as
normal in america
and you just don't be normal man normal
sucks
that's why you called us so i'm not
spanking you i'm going with you on this
i'm saying the answer to your question
is not about the truck the answer this
question's down inside of you
you fixed that and then you already know
you got to sell the truck the truck was
just off the chain it's got to go
but that's a side issue of course the
truck's got to go
it's dadgum almost as much as you make
in a year of course the truck
has to go it was a stupid idea to start
with of course the truck has to go
you don't rationalize i'm gonna visit
people three hours away and spend eighty
thousand dollars to do that
you go rent a car you go rent a house
over there
cheaper than that let's say you can rent
a house for five to ten years and
yeah it's cheaper than uber over there
exactly you can
you know charter a jet cheaper than this
and go see them twice a year you know i
mean it's just so
there's a lot of stuff you could do so
you can't use it you got to go okay that
didn't work
that didn't work that didn't work i knew
dave wasn't going to be happy with this
i knew my mentor wouldn't be happy with
this
is it because it affected dave or my
mentor no it's because they love me
and they want good things for me and
this wasn't good for me
and i got to not do stuff that's not
good for me anymore and know why i'm
doing it and break that cycle
and sell the truck let this be the last
one
brother i i do a lot of stupid stuff i
just try to not do the same stupid stuff
over again
and then if you do that long enough
eventually they call you wise